[Música]
de ser un personaje completamente
desconocido a convertirse en el
mismísimo jefe de estado un salto que
empieza a ser cada vez menos infrecuente
en la política internacional queridos
amigos amigas Ecuador tiene nuevo
presidente Daniel noboa y ya os adelanto
que no lo tendrá nada fácil en los
próximos años este país se enfrentará a
desafíos titánicos hablamos de
narcotráfico de conflictos indigenistas
y de una creciente oleada de violencia y
delincuencia que se está extendiendo por
todo el país Daniel Novoa heredero de un
imperio empresarial gana la elección
presidencial de Ecuador si bien la
victoria de Novoa Abre una nueva etapa
política en Ecuador Lo cierto es que
sigue habiendo muchos más interrogantes
que certezas especialmente por lo
particular que será este nuevo periodo
en el gobierno maana empezamos a
trabajar para reconstruir un país que ha
sido gravemente golpeado por la
violencia por la corrupción y por el
odio desde mañana empieza a trabajar la
esperanza desde mañana empieza a
trabajar Daniel Novoa su nuevo
presidente de la república Novoa solo
podrá terminar el mandato que le
correspondía terminar a Guillermo lazo
es decir que el nuevo presidente solo
estará al frente del ejecutivo
ecuatoriano desde diciembre de 2023
hasta mayo de 2025 por tanto su trabajo
será una carrera contra reloj con miles
de problemas múltiples promesas y unos
recursos y plazos Más bien justitos es
por eso que todos nos preguntamos Qué
significa realmente la llegada de Daniel
nobo al poder en Ecuador logrará llevar
a cabo todas las reformas prometidas en
apenas 17 meses logrará vencer al
narcotráfico y devolver la paz al
Ecuador Qué papel jugará el correísmo en
toda esta Aventura Pues bien Vamos con
ello pero antes dejadme haceros dos
preguntas la primera es estáis ya
suscritos a visual politic si no es así
no esperéis más es 100% gratuito y
podrás estar al tanto de todo el
contenido que está por llegar y la
segunda pregunta es todavía más clara
podrá Ucrania llegar a convertirse en la
promesa económica de Europa sí sé que
hablamos de un país en guerra pero podrá
Ucrania convertirse en una especie de
Nueva Polonia algo así como un centro de
fabricación competitivo a las puertas de
Europa pues ojo porque hay muchos
argumentos para sostener esta afirmación
si quieres saber más no te pierdas el
vídeo que ha hecho a este respecto si lo
hubieras sabido el canal de información
financiera de mutuactivos con el que
participamos en él Alberto nos cuenta
todos los detalles Así que os dejo un
enlace abajo en la descripción y también
por cierto al final de este vídeo y
dicho esto Ahora sí que sí continuemos
con
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Novoa
queridos amigos amigas en mayo de este
2023 el presidente Guillermo laso
sorprendió a todos cuando anunció la
aplicación de la muerte Cruzada Este
término trágico se utiliza para
describir un mecanismo constitucional
que consiste en la convocatoria
adelantada de elecciones para elegir un
nuevo poder ejecutivo y legislativo
disolviendo así sus respectivos mandatos
con la muerte Cruzada Guillermo lao le
devuelve al pueblo El poder de decidir
Su futuro en las próximas elecciones
para laso el Antiguo presidente esta
medida era la única opción de un
gobierno que prácticamente ya estaba
muerto desde 2022 el mismo se enfrentó a
varios impeachments y bloqueos
legislativos que hacían inviable
cualquier acción de gobierno para colmo
y como ya os contamos en febrero de 2023
lasso perdió un referéndum
constitucional con el que había sometido
a consulta popular diferentes ejes de su
plan de gobierno es decir que Elo no
contaba ni con el parlamento ni tampoco
con la sociedad ecuatoriana su
administración Estaba totalmente contra
las cuerdas y por eso el ya expresidente
vio en la muerte Cruzada una vía
institucional para intentar salir del
atolladero y quién sabe quizá también
escapar de ese infierno político he
escogido gobernar 6 meses en el
purgatorio en lugar de dos años en el
infierno con todo esto ya de paso el
expresidente consiguió llevarse por
delante a la asamblea nacional dominada
por la oposición Guillermo lao tuvo que
pensar algo así como Bueno si me tengo
que vio Pues nos vamos todos ya que
estamos así que dicho y hecho yo Admito
errores en mi gestión pero soy un
demócrata y he procurado que las
soluciones sean siempre
constitucionales ilegales he solicitado
al consejo nacional electoral la
convocatoria inmediata a elecciones
legislativas y
presidenciales para el resto de los
respectivos periodos la cuestión es que
Guillermo lazo ya no tenía ningún
capital político con el que poder apoyar
a un sucesor Así que la competición se
abrió de par en par con múltiples
partidos y múltiples
candidatos algunos candidatos
independientes como el periodista
Fernando villavicencio comenzaron a
ganar altura Aunque su trágico asesinato
terminó empañando toda la campaña
electoral luego algún que otro perfil
con alta experiencia como el
exvicepresidente de leni Moreno otos
sonen holder también intentaron hacerse
con la presidencia no obstante la única
plataforma que compitió claramente desde
el primer día fue Revolución ciudadana
el partido
correístas mejante beren genal se fue
colando poco a poco un tal Daniel noboa
un candidato que hizo de la discreción
la clave de su su
éxito primero nunca dijimos que
estábamos segundo porque el segundo
siempre le caen a palazos siempre lo
insultan siempre le dice o sea lo atacan
lo ataca a todo el
mundo y justo ahí fue cuando apareció
Novoa no solo consiguió pasar a la
segunda vuelta enfrentándose
directamente al correísmo sino que logró
hacerse con la victoria final Pero de
dónde salió exactamente noboa Cuál es
realmente su ideología Y cómo es que
logró ganarse la confianza del 52 de los
Ecuatorianos en apenas unas pocas
semanas Pues prestad mucha atención
porque el ahora presidente más joven de
la historia de Ecuador ha tenido una
carrera meteórica una carrera que será
clave para comprender la dirección y el
rumbo que adoptará su nuevo
gobierno outsider pero no
[Música]
tanto quizás Daniel novo acín fuese un
perfil poco conocido para la opinión
pública ecuatoriana pero desde luego ese
no es el caso de su familia La familia
del nuevo presidente está muy presente
en la en los círculos empresariales y
políticos del país de hecho lo están
incluso desde hace ya varias
generaciones Daniel forma parte de la
tercera generación de una familia de
empresarios multimillonarios de gu
alquil su abuelo Luis Novoa Naranjo
fundó y gestionó la exportadora bananera
Novoa un negocio que le permitió ser
durante el siglo 20 uno de los hombres
más ricos de todo Ecuador más tarde el
padre de Daniel Álvaro Novoa pontón
expandió el negocio familiar más allá
bajo la insignia del grupo Novoa creando
con ella un conglomerado empresarial muy
diversificado cuyas actividades van
desde la agroexportación hasta la
gestión de negocios inmobiliarios Aunque
claro está la diversificación no solo
giró en el entorno privado Álvaro fue un
político de gran peso hacia los años
2000 de hecho llegó a ser candidato
presidencial en cinco ocasiones e
incluso pasó a tres segundas
vueltas Álvaro nobo obtuvo el 48 por de
los votos en la segunda vuelta de 1998
en el año 2002 volvió a quedarse a las
puertas de la presidencia se hizo con el
45 por y en el año 2006 tuvo su última
elección competitiva llegó a una segunda
vuelta donde se con un joven político un
tal Rafael Correa nada que
hacer luego por otro lado Anabel ainn la
esposa de Álvaro y la madre del actual
presidente llegó a acompañar la fórmula
presidencial de la familia en 2009 y
2013 digamos que los Novoa querían a
toda Costa la presidencia y de hecho la
rozaron en tres ocasiones pero ha sido
justo Ahora cuando la han conseguido de
la mano de su hijo Daniel quien De hecho
no era muy visible en el espectro
político sea como sea su presencia a la
familia Novoa lo vincula directamente
con las élites sociales económicas y
diferentes círculos de poder en Ecuador
por tanto no hablamos de alguien que ha
parecido de la nada y que no tiene
ningún poder ahora bien Más allá de su
historia familiar Qué hay de él qué hay
de su vida Pues si os parece echamos un
vistazo muy
[Música]
rápido con tan solo 36 años Daniel nooa
estudió administración de negocios en la
universidad de Nueva York y también
obtuvo un título de administración
pública en la Harvard Kennedy School y
otro título en gobernanza y comunicación
política por la universidad George
Washington vamos lo que se dice un
currículum Aparentemente completito
luego su carrera profesional la ha
desarrollado por supuesto en las
empresas familiares donde llegó a ser
director naviero y director comercial y
de logística sea como sea en 2021 dio su
primer paso en la política fue elegido
legislador por la provincia de Santa
Helena con una candidatura vinculada a
partidarios de Lenin Moreno en la
asamblea nacional del Ecuador Daniel
llegó a presidir la comisión de
desarrollo económico en el
[Música]
parlamento más de la mitad de los
Ecuatorianos depositaron su confianza en
Daniel noboa y finalmente este apellido
Ha logrado hacerse con la jefatura del
Estado ecuatoriano Y eso nos lleva
directamente a una de las preguntas
clave en este vídeo Qué espera hacer
noboa en 17 meses Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a
[Música]
ver el plan
Novoa la candidatura de Novoa estuvo
impulsada por la acción democrática
nacional un partido recién creado en
noviembre de 2022 que tuvo que aliarse
con otros partidos más pequeños para
poder tener un registro válido ante el
Consejo Nacional electoral en este
sentido Novoa Se presenta como un
político de centro y aunque él se ha
referido a sí mismo como un
socialdemócrata Lo cierto es que
desarrolló una campaña donde la
ideología tuvo muy poco peso digamos que
noboa evitó entrar en debates dogmáticos
Supongo que por una cuestión de
pragmatismo electoral y mucha gente
especialmente el correísmo quiere
encasillar en una derecha cuando nuestro
proyecto político es un proyecto de
Centro centro izquierda es un
progresismo responsable es una social
democracia moderada es la libre empresa
con responsabilidad social en su plan de
gobierno podemos ver algunas medidas de
corte progresista Como por ejemplo el
incremento del salario mínimo la
promoción de la negociación colectiva
del trabajo o el establecimiento de
leyes más severas que sancionen la
evasión fiscal y permitan que el estado
recaude más dinero Asimismo noboa
también ha prometido llevar a cabo una
revisión exhaustiva de las políticas de
inversión de los fondos de jubilación
para que el estado pueda intervenir y
mejorar el sistema de pensiones un
sistema que actualmente tiene una
composición mixta en la que participan
tanto el Instituto ecuatoriano de la
seguridad social como fondos
privados otra faceta que ha destacado la
campaña de noboa ha sido las propuestas
en torno a la diversidad este candidato
se ha comprometido a promover la
integración de los inmigrantes reconocer
las nacionalidades indígenas y promover
activamente la no discriminación de la
población
[Música]
lgtbi es decir que hablamos de un
candidato que en gran medida encajaría
con el típico perfil de la
socialdemocracia europea tiene gracia
que el correísmo haya perdido contra un
candidato socialdemócrata no os parece
Eso sí en el terreno económico y de
empresas su perfil es mucho más prom
mercado y desde luego defiende
ferreamente la dolarización la
protección de la dolarización es crucial
dado que una economía estable y
predecible es un requisito fundamental
para atraer inversión tanto interna como
externa y generar empleo para proteger y
reforzar la dolarización es fundamental
mantener la disciplina fiscal y la
responsabilidad en la gestión de las
finanzas públicas además se debe Buscar
incrementar las reservas internacionales
lo que proporcionará una red de
seguridad en caso de shocks económicos
externos en última instancia su perfil
de empresario lo ha convertido en un
líder cómodo para los sectores
productivos además ha situado como una
de sus grandes prioridades atraer la
inversión extranjera especialmente en el
campo de la energía y del petróleo sin
embargo 17 meses es muy poco tiempo y no
dudéis que eso es algo que el propio
Novoa tiene muy claro Y quizá por eso
los dos temas que persiga con más
celeridad en su presidencia serán
primero hacer cambios en el sistema
educativo hoy en día de 340,000 jóvenes
que aplican a una universidad pública
solo 140,000 obtuvieron un cupo
universitario hay 200,000 jóvenes hoy en
día de 18 años que no obtuvieron un cupo
en una universidad pública Qué tipo de
cambios pues por ejemplo no va ha
prometido incrementar el gasto público y
la inversión en educación superior según
el nuevo presidente Esta es la mejor
forma de enfrentar y erradicar la
militancia blanda pero a ver a ver a ver
qué es eso de la militancia blanda Pues
básicamente los jóvenes que son
manejados por los grupos de narcotráfico
lo que nos lleva directamente al segundo
tema clave sa que podemos esperar de su
presidencia efectivamente la seguridad y
sabéis qué creo que aquí una imagen vale
más que 1
[Música]
palabras en los últimos años la
criminalidad de Ecuador se ha disparado
y está batiendo todos los registros
históricos el número de omicidios por
100,000 habitantes se han multiplicado
prácticamente por cinco en los últimos 5
años todo una locura No pues para
intentar poner freno a este desmadre
nobo ha prometido reorganizar y mejorar
los servicios de inteligencia
precisamente para que puedan realizar
operativos de alto nivel algo que hoy
por hoy y no parece que las fuerzas de
seguridad sean capaces de hacerlo el
Ecuador no tiene una agencia
inteligencia consolidada tiene
inteligencia de la policía inteligencia
de los militares inteligencia que se
reporta al presidente de la república
como todo está desarticulado no se puede
dar la fórmula para que la policía y los
militares puedan atacar a las
organizaciones
narcodictadura una reforma del Código
Penal para mejorar la situación de los
procesados sin sentencia y los
delincuentes no violentos la idea de
esto es incluir nuevos tipos es decir
penas alternativas a la prisión para los
delitos no violentos La pregunta es por
qué pues entre otras cosas porque las
cárceles del país ya no dan para más las
cárceles ecuatorianas están saturadas y
los responsables pues no dan a basto en
cierto modo eso explica que cada dos por
tres se produzcan peleas de bandas
asesinatos de presos y masacres
carcelarias de hecho el nuevo presidente
quiere segmentar a los presos por su
nivel de peligrosidad e incluso ha
propuesto meter a los más peligrosos en
barcos carcelarios qué os
[Música]
parece
en cualquier caso como veis hablamos de
políticas que en general buscan dar
resultados relativamente rápidos Al fin
y al cabo una caída en la tasa de
criminalidad y alguna mejora educativa
serían Dos Banderas electorales
fantásticas para el 2025 y por eso estos
dos Campos serán casi seguro la
prioridad número uno del nuevo
presidente Es verdad que un año y medio
no es que se puede cambiar el mundo si
se pueden cambiar varias cosas clave
reducir la violencia darle oportunidad a
la juventud ahora bien novan no va a
gobernar solo el corre sigue al acecho
dos elecciones en las que han competido
a cara de perro hacen que el fantasma de
Rafael Correa siga muy presente en los
círculos del poder en Ecuador y la
pregunta es qué significó este nuevo
revés para Rafael Correa Por qué la
sociedad ante el fracaso de aso no le
dio un voto de confianza al correísmo Es
realmente imposible el regreso de correa
al Ecuador Pues
[Música]
atentos el fin del correísmo
Rafael Correa llegó al poder en el año
2006 justamente cuando logró derrumbar
al padre de Daniel Álvaro noboa logró
completar tres mandatos convirtiéndose
en la figura hegemónica de la política
ecuatoriana su poder parecía ilimitado
pero ojo en 2017 su Aliado y sucesor
Lenin Moreno cambió de rumbo y
diferentes investigaciones judiciales
señalaron a Correa como el responsable
de multimillonarias tramas de corrupción
por eso desde el año 2018 los tribunales
Ecuatorianos exigen su detención aunque
él vive como refugiado político en
Bruselas
desde entonces su partido la revolución
ciudadana rc ha continuado haciendo
campaña y ha sido la principal oposición
a lenín Moreno y a Guillermo lazo sin
embargo con Correa fuera del país rc no
ha estado Ni cerca de repetir su
resultado electoral de 2013 cuando logró
ganar en primera vuelta en 2017 ganaron
Sí pero aquello solo sirvió para llevar
a la hora antic correístas leni Moreno
al
poder en estas últimas elecciones
Revolución ciudadana que es el partido
de correa se presentó a las elecciones
con otra candidata Luisa González
evidentemente Correa desde Bruselas y
perseguido por la justicia no se pudo
presentar sin embargo como ya hemos
dicho la elección presidencial de
Ecuador estuvo repleta de otros
candidatos independientes y muchísimos
partidos pequeños unidos por un solo
tema común el anticorr todo el mundo iba
en contra de Correa y esto es algo que
él mismo calificó como los poderes
enormes Patria querida patria grande
esta vez no lo logramos enfrentamos
poderes enormes hasta se asesinó a un
candidato para evitar nuestra Victoria
la traición de Lenin Moreno sigue
causando estragos pero que nadie dude De
que al final Ecuador volverá a la senda
del desarrollo y la integración
latinoamericana hasta la victoria
siempre pero llegados a este punto cabe
recalcar que la derrota del partido de
correa esta vez no ha sido normal Esta
vez tiene un tinte algo
diferente el liderazgo de la nueva
candidata Luisa González ha renovado
gran parte de la cúpula del partido un
partido donde ya comienza a sonar la
necesidad de ganar autonomía respecto a
la deteriorada imagen de Rafael Correa y
amigos pensad que aún ligados al
expresidente el techo electoral del
partido Parece ser no mayor al 47 del
voto algo que de hecho los deja muy
cerca de ganar unas potenciales
elecciones y la cuestión es que algunas
voces dentro del partido creen que ganar
solo Será posible si Correa se hace
definitivamente a un lado y queréis una
prueba de este cambio de tono en la
Esfera del partido político Pues fijaos
en Cómo el correísmo reconoció la
derrota electoral en 2021 Comparado con
Cómo la reconocido ahora en 2023
estaremos atentos ante cualquier intento
de usar estado para beneficio de pocos
privilegiados estaremos como siempre lo
hemos hecho defendiendo a las grandes
mayorías al pueblo digno al pueblo
ecuatoriano cuente con nuestros votos en
la asamblea para las reformas legales
para la seguridad para salud para
educación entre la victoria de Novoa y
la posible reestructuración del partido
de correa sin Correa el panorama
político ecuatoriano podría estar
cambiando rápidamente y la pregunta es
qué podemos esperar a nivel
institucional en estos 17 meses se
producirá un nuevo bloqueo legislativo
fue realmente la muerte Cruzada una
buena idea Pues bien Vamos a
[Música]
verlo un Nuevo
Horizonte amigos y amigas ya sabéis que
aquí en visual politic tenemos una
premisa ocuparnos de los temas clave de
la agenda internacional y sabéis que
latinoamérica últimamente no deja de
darnos trabajo el estallido social de
chile el regreso de Lula al poder el
intento de golpe de estado de Pedro
Castillo o sin ir más lejos las
elecciones argentinas con milei y masa
por momentos la región parece
ingobernable y desde luego Ecuador no
parece precisamente un Oasis en medio de
toda esa realidad Aunque eso sí con
algunos matices en las últimas
elecciones Ecuador acaba de registrar
una participación electoral récord
digamos que los Ecuatorianos tienen
ganas de un cambio y de hecho la opción
vencedora parece representar una Clara
ruptura con su pasado es decir Ecuador
parecería contar ahora con un nuevo
proyecto político que no remite ni a
Correa ni a Moreno ni a guill molo me
dicen que soy laista otros me dicen que
soy correístas otros me dicen que soy
leninista al final del día yo soy Pro
Ecuador y tengo mi propia determinación
y tengo mi propio proyecto político aquí
Ecuador ha roto con la tendencia
regional si Perú entró en una carrera de
autodestrucción tras la caída de Pedro
Pablo kucinski si Brasil tras la
destitución de dilm rusev le dio su voto
de confianza a bolsonaro en Ecuador han
apostado por la moderación algo muy raro
en Latinoamérica Claro que todavía Hay
un problema la composición legislativa
el bloque de noboa apenas cuenta con 14
diputados en un espacio donde se
necesitan al menos 69 legisladores para
tener una mayoría mínima Así que si el
nuevo presidente quiere sacar adelante
las reformas le va a tocar tener que
dialogar mucho pero que mucho con el
resto de partidos sobre la mesa los
números están servidos para que se
produzca un nuevo bloqueo parlamentario
y es aquí donde entra la acción de
campaña de noboa al llegar como el
moderado sin haber chocado abiertamente
con nadie ni siquiera con el correísmo
le da una nueva oportunidad la pregunta
es sabrá aprovecharla Pues por ahora la
victoria de Novoa le ha dado a Ecuador
una salida institucional y pacífica a
una grave crisis política las cartas
están echadas solo el tiempo nos dirá si
se cumplen o no las expectativas
generadas pero ahora llegados hasta aquí
el turno es para todos vosotros qué
piensas sobre el perfil de centro de
nooa crees que es el adecuado para
liderar Ecuador Durante los próximos 17
meses volveremos a ver un nuevo bloqueo
político Pues como siempre podéis
dejarnos vuestras respuestas en los
comentarios si este vídeo te ha gustado
te ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle a like y suscribirte a visual
politic si es que todavía no lo has
hecho muchas Gracias por estar aquí con
todos nosotros y nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo un saludo y hasta
[Música]
pronto